why don't we do cover burgers at fall
Richland Nick my organic burger made
with totally fresh ingredients and miles
away from art defy crap nothing wrong
with a burger
welcome to proper cooking and it's
cheaper to mate and bought in silicon
implants tomato chutney it's a nice raw
cherry tomato chutney with shewhart's
put a little bit of parmesan on tasting
the celebration burger lovely so far
Nick and Richard I've shown little
interest in the food they're serving
what's the verdict
that fantastic absolutely brilliant man
it's just that's the talking point that
is that's it more place and the burgers
are awesome you got to go there and have
all fresh beefiness and because burgers
are traditionally so badly done what an
opportunity to really excel I can almost
see them counting the money they could
make with my American themed burgers and
corned beef hash pecan pie Peach Melba
and smoked haddock chowder the most
important thing about this particular
service is it yeah it's been up in the
morning time Charlotte made up using
potatoes the clam juice thicken it we've
got a little step further than poached
and quails eggs then pour the chana
over the haddock over the clams quail
eggs two mice and running inside that's
something you take this blue thing
wish the food is really coming together
listen the corned beef hash with
hollandaise finish with cranberry
mustard not they've got a little
exception really not finally we're
getting somewhere now we need is some
customers 35,000 golfers use this place
every bloody year you know yeah and
there's a small percentage of them I can
get in don't bloody restaurant through
there so the idea now is going round
there stalk them a little bit on the
green and ask them to taste this amazing
food I'm taking Kim one of the
waitresses and Andy to entice them in
with the food morning sir
how you doing looks like a quick burger
sir thank you very much what in it what
is your night off that is in aid of
handy ok very chef in the restaurant at
one place
are you we haven't used it I'm been that
place for four years four years ago I
used to come down this on a Sunday and
we booked a breakfast and the other T
booked and he just took so long to get
the breakfast it Hey
well we had to tee off on that to leave
the breakfast night I've been in there
since Nick and Richard can't keep an
empty restaurant gone forever we have to
fill the dying room and make customers
come back this is a beautiful mini
hamburger why it's gonna go mad now let
me start all down you jumped on he camp
I wonder how many of these golfers are
ex customers trust the brand inna just
trying to get people into the restaurant
try my good food is there a theme to
your menu chowder um great burgers come
beef hash beautiful rose
um Knickerbocker glorious lien would you
come out to the Russians
oh they certainly would
there are three days of a year and all
restaurants however bad a full New
Year's Eve Valentine's night and
Mother's Day that's a good point it's
Mother's Day this Sunday and it could be
make or break for more place three down
thirty four thousand nine hundred and
ninety seven to go